the attack happened at this house on
this estate near kephili
the boy who's now been named as jack
liss had gone to his friends to play
after school
neighbors say they first realized
something was terribly wrong when they
heard a commotion outside there was
children screaming everybody was out in
the street we just seen
there was a lot of police cars and
ambulances
despite a rapid response the police say
the ten-year-old boy could not be saved
the dog was destroyed by marksman
people living around here have told me
they used to see the dog in the street
and they've described it as a scary
looking animal that resembled a pit bull
but they stress they don't know what
type of breed it was
that is now a focus of the police
investigation
officers say it will take time to
establish all the facts it's not
possible for me to formally identify to
identify the breed of dog at this
current time
so you can't say whether it was banned
under the dangerous dogs that's correct
so
that will be formally done by
an expert witness a dog legislation
officer as flowers were laid in tributes
jack's mother made an emotional post on
facebook describing her son as a sweet
sweet boy
this close-knit community is deeply
traumatized we had
tea
last night and
then had to break the sad news to them
and
it was well devastating
forensic officers are still at the
property gathering evidence police say a
significant presence will remain here
whilst they continue their
investigations
alex rossi sky news south wales